If there's one thing we can all agree on
it's that everybody hates hipsters, right?
You know, it's the common enemy that
we all have that will unite us,
that will remove all race and gender
boundaries and we will say we,
our humanity like Independence Day,
and we will fight against the hipsters.
Even the hipsters themselves
who, apparently,
don't even know that they are
hipsters will also hate hipsters.
Everybody is against the same
thing and its kind of,
it's kind of beautiful
in a way.
So you can imagine the horror
that you would experience
if you started noticing some these hipster-like
tendencies appearing in your life.
That, my friends, if I can still
call you friends after this,
is what I am suffering
from right now.
I think the biggest and most telling example
for me was when I bought those glasses.
I mean, just look at that.
To be wearing the glasses.
The actual Ray Band Wayfarers that you put
on something to turn it into a hipster.
This is-- That's how you turn Ariel into
Hipster Ariel by putting these on.
And yet, I am not going to do
anything about it.
Like, these were expensive glasses
and I think I look good in them.
This is when this worry started
for me was when I was
sitting in like a trendy
warehouse-type coffee bar,
looking around me thinking,
"Heh, there's a hipster there.
Oh, there another one.
Look at his funny mustache.
Uh...everyone is a hipster here.
Why am I here?"
So my interpretation of the hipster-like
personality constitutes a couple things.
First off: you like things ironically.
That, I think I can comfortably say
is something that I don't do.
I have my things that I like a lot and I like
maybe even to some people too much,
but I don't care 'cause
I like them.
That to me is a nerd, but then
there's the whole, you know,
"You know that thing that
everybody likes now,
I don't like it but when
nobody liked it,
that's when I was a big fan.
Oh, aren't I cool."
That's the thing I think that we
all center on as being like,
"Eww. Hipsters.
What rubbish people."
But I have to be honest
with myself and think,
"Have I ever been that person?
Have I ever been in the
situation where I'm like,
'Ooh! I liked that thing before everybody else did.
Doesn't that make me cool?'"
And honestly, I have. I feel like as much as
I can try to point out and justify
the things about me that aren't
hipster-esque and be like,
"No, hipsters are like this,
and I don't do that sort of thing,"
there is a nugget in my heart that
is enjoying things ironically.
There is definitely a sense of comfort
that I get when I am in a warehouse
that's been converted to a coffee shop,
surrounded by lots of trendy looking people.
I feel at home in that--
they're cozy!
They do a good job decorating.
I think if there is a moral
to be found here,
I don't want to find it because the moral is that
I think there's probably--there's either -
this will be more comfortable - there's either
a little bit more hipster in all of us
or there is a little bit of hipster
in me, specifically,
and I am a hipster but I don't want
to have to deal with that
and the consequences
of being that person.
I could, at least, be the first
person who will actually admit
that they are a bit of a hipster as
opposed to all of the other hipsters
that don't want to admit it.
There we go.
That's how I can feel superior.
Alright. Charlie out.
STEPHEN FRY VOICE: You've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching charlieissocoollike,
which makes you, like, cool.
Okie dokie, last week's video
in case you missed it,
which is likely because of the way that
YouTube works these days. Hahahaha.
And, also, the trailer for my new
short film because, you know,
I will continue to promote this
until everyone on the planet
has seen it because that's what
you do when you make a film.
Thank you very much for sticking around.
Have a nice day.